day five of the US and US Women's Chess  Championship here in st. Louis with  winds raining down from the sky the best  players in the country returned to do  battle on the nation's largest stage Sam  Shanklin had a golden opportunity to  defeat a wounded Fabiano Khurana but the  World Championship Challenger saved the  day  leaving Shanklin soul and a Cobian still  in a tie for first arena crush was close  to defeating co-leader Nancy by Kizzy  but tenacious defense by the 2016 champ  left her in a tie with one Durkin anyway  with the rest of the pack giving chase  it's the day before the rest day with  players usually give it their all round  six action coming up next  [Music]